like how comfortable I can that real
comfortable hosting thing I got this
like stiff body language what's up guys
I'm Greg
hi I'm Ashley Ashley enter has finally
returned to the channel you finally
asked me back finally I know got a few
cats you're definitely allergic a whole
office for like an hour and a half
yesterday popping some allergy pills and
I'm here now she's here try not to laugh
video with different family life forever
ago still getting views and I constantly
see comments of like one is actually
gonna come back so now that you're here
we have to do I try not to laugh and I
failed miserably last time and I figured
since I've seen almost every episode of
Family Guy home boy Tyrone Magnus did
cover this one on aired Family Guy
deleted scenes compilation so I don't
know if I've seen any deleted scenes
from Family Guy so it should be a real
challenge
you ready action yes well we Koreans do
not
and now a public service announcement
from husbands - what hello wives did you
know that filling up the eyestrain takes
only two seconds here are other things
that only take two seconds turning off
the light
putting the tops on stuff hanging of a
towel also how about some sex
I'm tired of masturbating in the
bathroom after you go to bed we now
return to Extreme Home Makeover troubled
last week in addition oh hi I just
finished my two liter of Mountain Dew
what's that outside when we can right
now to us he left all his power tools so
now that's real potato but it's not that
great but it's so here's an old
microwave i bashed into a tree under the
house it's a good place to throw this
stuff might break and kill ok let's take
a break and show us her hairs no he
doesn't he never knows what he's doing
those are kind of what he gave that
deposition look I don't think I'm any
different from anybody else sometimes
you got time to kill it on temporal
sometimes there's a mirror on the wall
sometimes you look at your own stink
hole in the mirror push your own stuff
up game it's fine just you buy all kinds
of looks pull one teeth to the side
maybe both get out of camera watch it
later up a different angle
what status come on pretend you're a
doctor why should they manage it anyone
could me sir the question was is this
your signature
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you tried to wash it down but there's
only so many days in to shoot forth dog
nailed it
we all cried when we brought it back to
the bow oh this is PBS funding for this
program is made possible by the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting and
viewers like you
I think it's possible it's day three of
quahogs new ban on alcohols for anybody
under 50 and if there's one thing the
new drinking age law has done its let us
know that women tell terrible stories
we're talking more
let's listen in did anyone see what
Cheryl yeah I was fine what's eat sushi
are there was a weird first thing to say
Peter
all you ever send me a lens to old man
pleasure in each other okay good so at
least you're out there looking dad's
right I'm gonna keep everyone on this
stretch safe like Captain America
Captain America can I see you shield for
a second sure
here you go he's just a guy we now
return to will they eat a deviled egg
he
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
mr. president scraps can one guy trying
to sneak her bottom into these jeans one
cheek at a time
she can't dress when she gotta be dry
around it was that yeah like those guys
who hang around comic book shops all day
even though they don't work in so no
need to put any vintage comics and
plastic sleeves I think we're good all
right well I'll just stand in the back
and play with myself over my jeans that
was really great Jake really really
great
your face is upside down so we're not
gonna pick you but thanks for coming
come on just change the egg I'm upside
down for peanut butter that's one right
there peanut butter turns that frown
upside down that's I can keep going
peanut butter it you have two girls
and this is the fightin lip
she's a b-17 and she flew the most
bombing sorties in the European theater
and waiters Snoopy's doghouse that was
stolen by a fat guy in a ski mask oh
yeah this is Wow thank you thank you
when I get home I'll transfer enough
money so you can rebuild your town
you've all been very kind
it's interesting with missing sound
effects Peter always thinking it's the
rise of the machines
[Laughter]
well you're right we don't fix him so
big a disaster morning everybody thank
you sir
[Music]
[Music]
we did it we did it
technically law considers this a win and
lose I mean is supposed to be it's
supposed to be a challenge
Greg man up I lost the challenge the one
that did it for me was the dog in the
farm and then the beer that was the one
that got it free yeah I don't know why
mine was the deviled eggs
I don't know so it's also like deviled
eggs I mean at least to me like aren't
very appetizing that's subjective
okay I don't like pickles I do but I
don't like deviled eggs though mmm if it
was a pickle I thought these jokes would
be like exceptionally vulgar and edgy
because there was no beard yeah but I
was like okay I guess some of these
bitter is not that great I mean some of
them were sad I know right we're all
depressing I did like the one though
with Peter going on his ranch in the
conference so funny that was a hard one
for me not to laugh to you when it comes
to Peter like he does make me laugh the
most
once he's got the delivery of his lines
yeah are just the best oh I liked the
brunch one too because that's actually
super true
you're speaking for a woman right now
listen to like girls like at brunch with
their mimosas like it's gonna be way
more entertaining you were not woken
you're not an advocate for women you're
saying the only way women can be
entertaining otherwise if they had booze
in them I feel like at the brunch table
they're like commenting on the outfits
and that girl was like yeah what she was
wearing this
I wonder why some of these recut a lot
of these just seemed like good enough
Family Guy bits to have been in any one
of their many random segments that they
throw in throughout the universe exactly
are you the next peanut butter kid
moment I thought was hilarious funny man
so that's his son yeah we've never seen
him before have we
we have halfway oh my god yes you are
not paying attention a family guy Laura
well I don't I haven't seen all the
episodes well man the guy is linear you
pay attention to their flashbacks they
all tell one cohesive storyline all
right but he's been in it yeah he's a
freak who cares and then there poor Meg
making her way you know it's like I mean
I don't know but you know as a woman you
should understand right it's not funny
when I make the joke all right guys
we'll try not to laugh and the guy we
did it we brought you back for the main
thing you were required here to be four
oh thank you I hope I did okay I will be
able to sleep embarrass myself on the
real rejects today damn it subscribe
click that Bell wow that's evidence
again and hey paint you to the day's
shadow
chrislam off our friend from Michigan
this one's gonna be a little bit
different because he wanted to
specifically dedicate his shout out to a
dear friend of his Lisa legio she
actually passed away at this time last
year March 15 2019 at the age of 42 as
an activist and she committed a good
chunk of her life to making the world a
better place as a matter of fact her
sent me over this video she was part of
this protest and an oil pipeline spill
in 2010 in Michigan she logged in over
650 hours in the Sandy relief effort she
helped an organization called Sandy
Claws which helped people getting prom
dresses for Christmas items helped to
mold remediation to poor families she
helped out in Oklahoma after some
tornado disasters bottom line she was
extremely passionate about mutual aid
and community he did put out this
Facebook post I just wanted to read a
few of the posts from people who
contributed to the page one person here
Amanda Robinson says she was always the
one that was good with words love you
Lisa
Melissa ray says I am so grateful for
the opportunity to meet her before she
passed I loved her fire and willingness
to put herself out there for others
Tammy hibner says the way she not only
had such a strong voice but how she
valved they didn't encourage others I
miss her Susan Wallen said you don't
have to include this but I want to I'll
tell you she made makes a difference in
my life she reached out to me while I
was living working in Flint and had been
arrested for no good reason April 2017
she reached out over Facebook and was
trying to meet up the way my mind was at
the time with PTSD brain I couldn't get
myself to go talk to her I was an
avoiding exhausted hyper alert mode even
I go to group events which I did low-key
and saw her there literally dancing
around being awesome just her reaching
I'm making a connection to show support
with what I was going through meant so
much to me and still does I knew she had
something similar happened with the
MCATs accident so I felt like she
probably knew how I was feeling I do
feel bad for not getting back to her but
also like she'd understand I deactivated
Facebook for a long time when I got back
on scene something happened couldn't
believe it she courageously showed up
for others to help ease suffering and
show strength she was inspiring still is
and is missed I wish more people cared
like that there's actually a lot of
posts on this Facebook page and I've
actually read every single one of them I
watched this whole video and I wish I
got to know Lisa she seemed like an
incredibly generous kind hard-working
human being always fought to make the
world a better place someone who's been
more I mean pretty private about it but
I've been more active and
other ways what I can do in the world
I've certainly never risen up to the
level of contribution that Lisa herself
has done but Lisa I wish I hadn't met
you I'm sorry we had to lose you even
though you're gone now your impact still
solidifies that you are an inspiration
to those you met and you're still
continuing to inspire people such as
myself estanque you so much for sharing
the information about her and I'm glad I
could share this information about Lisa
the rest of the world